[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires et nous allons prendre
tout de suite la direction de Bordeaux
où le président de la République doit
prononcer un discours sur la protection
sociale et sur la lutte contre les
fraudes sociales élevé au thème numéro 1
pour les Français direction Bordeaux le
président de la République vient de
prendre la parole la mesure de la
renaissance de Bordeaux et donc du
formidable travail entrepris depuis des
années par Alain Jupé que je veux sal
et que je veux
remercier je me souvenz aussi que de
cette même ville de ces mêmes quaai au
moment où notre pays s'abîmait dans la
défaite et que certains faisaient acte
de
défétisme un homme le général de Gaulle
partait rejoindre
l'Angleterre pour s'atteler à la
renaissance de la
France c'est dans le combat contre
l'occupant que l'ensemble des mouvements
de
résistance chrétiens
Gaulistes socialistes communistes ont
défini le fameux programme du Conseil
National de la
Résistance de cette solidarité de la
France combattante est née une ambition
nouvelle pour la France une ambition
généreuse inscrite dans le marbre de nos
lois fondamentales car d
1946 la nouvelle
Constitution garantissait à tous les
citoyens de notre pays la protection de
la santé et la sécurité
matérielle conçu par la résistance né
avec la
libération notre modèle social fait
aujourd'hui partie de l'identité de
notre nation les Français sont
attachés vicéralement attachés
car il est le fruit de notre histoire et
de nos valeurs et dans le contexte de
crise économique et financière qui est
le nôtre aujourd'hui en tant que chef de
l'État je suis le
garant et mon devoir est d'être le
protecteur de notre modèle
social faut-il rappeler que dans notre
pays nous ne laissons pas au bord du
chemin ceux qui sont frappés par la
maladie par
l'âge par la dépendance ou par le
handicap faut-il rappeler en
France on ne perd pas sa couverture
maladie quand on perd son
emploi faut-il rappeler qu'en France on
ne perd pas sa
retraite par le fait des Herm de la
finance
internationale faut-il rappeler qu'en
France on garantit au plus démunis un
accès aux soins
absolument sans équivalent dans le
monde et bien je le rappelle aujourd'hui
devant vous car il faut un lassablement
rappeler que
l'honneur de la France c'est d'avoir
construit une république
démocratique sociale sur les décombres
de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale je tiens à rappeler cette
vérité
car quand j'entends dire ici ou là que
le pacte de 1945 serait remise en cause
que les valeurs et les idéaux du Conseil
National de la Résistance seraiit foulé
au pied et que nous serions en train de
trahir l'héritage que nous on laissé les
pères de notre modèle social je veux
dire que je n'accepte pas ces mensonges
et que je n'accepte pas ces
outrances je les refuse et je suis venu
ici à Bordeaux pour les réfuter point
par
point je veux dire que ceux qui ont
trahi l'héritage du Conseil National de
la
Résistance ce sont ceux qui depuis des
décennie ont refusé toute réforme par
lâcheté politique ou par
opportunisme là est la trahison de notre
social
ceux qui ont trahi l'héritage du Conseil
National de la
Résistance ce sont ceux qui pendant des
décennies ont bien soigneusement
dissimulé aux
Français qu'il finançai leur système de
protection sociale à coup de déficit et
à cou de
dette voilà donc que pendant des
décennies on a protégé les Français à
crédit sans le dire au français
on a protégé les français des années 80
en hypothéquant
l'avenir de leurs enfants et de leurs
petits-enfants là est la vérité et là
est la trahison de l'esprit et de la
lettre de notre modèle
social avec la réforme des retraites de
2010 et les efforts de tous les
Français nous avons voulu sauver la
vieillesse de la sécurité
sociale un travailleur qui a été salarié
au Smic pendant toute sa vie
professionnelle bénéficier ainsi d'un
taux de remplacement égal à 85 % du
Smith net la réforme des retraites de
2010 a préservé un acquis social majeur
ce qui refusent la réforme des retraites
sont prêts à détruire un acquis
soci majeur la réforme des retraites
nous l'avons mise en uvre pour protéger
l'acquis sociale des
Français regardons autour de nous mes
chers
compatriotes et chacun pourra
constater que dans la
crise les retraités
français ont été
davantage préservé et protégé que
partout ailleurs en
Europe il en va de même pour la
situation de la branche famille
elle est l'une des plus
généreuses et des plus efficaces au
monde elle conjugue l'universalité dans
l'accès aux allocations familiales et le
soutien ciblé aux familles les plus
défavorisées avec l'investissement
massif dans les politiques d'accueil du
jeune enfant que nous réalisons la
politique familiale est un pilier
central du dynam de notre pays et je
n'accepterai jamais la remise en cause
des fondamentaux de notre politique
familial car les résultats sont là nous
parvenons à concilier en France un taux
de natalité
élevé de plus de 2 enfants par
femme avec un taux d'activité féminin de
% la France a tout fait pour que les
femmes puissent connaître un un
épanouissement
professionnel sans renoncer à un
épanouissement familial année après
année notre population active continue
de croître dans 20 ans la population de
la France sera crue de 20 % alors
qu'elle aura baissé dans H autres pays
européens notamment
l'Allemagne il nit de richesse codom
écrivait au 16e siècle grand humanisme
français Jean Budin bien cette richesse
la France ass la préseré parce qu'elle
s'est dotée d'une politique familiale
sans nul autre pareil en Europe la
France est en train de
redevenir ce qu'elle fut pendant des
siècles la première puissance
démographique d'Europe dans 30 ans la
France aura davantage d'habitants que
l'Allemagne regardons enfin la branche
maladie
elle prend en charge plus des 3/4 des
dépenses de santé engagé par les
Français et quoi qu'en disent les
critiques même avec les progrès de la
médecine et l'augmentation des coût ce
taux est stable depuis 15 ans notre
système de santé est l'un des meilleur
au monde Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
compatriotes la proportion de la
richesse nationale ainsi dévolue à la
protection sociale un/ers de notre PIB
fait de la France
l'un des pays les plus généreux sur le
plan social il faut que chacun d'entre
nous et bien cette réalité à
l'esprit c'est une chance et c'est un
atout c'est un atout parce que j'ai la
conviction que les économies se portent
mieux lorsqu'il existe des régimes de
protection sociale efficace et je
conteste
l'équation
croissance faiblesse du modèle social
la protection sociale efficace permet
d'améliorer la productivité des
salariés et de favoriser une croissance
équilibré et durable c'est cette même
conviction que nous avons soutenu au G20
avec Alain Jupé Xavier Bertrand pour la
première fois des pays comme les
États-Unis l'Inde la Chine le Brésil ont
reconnu la nécessité de construire dans
chaque pays un socle de protection
sociale le chemin est long mais la voix
est ouverte et c'est la France qui l'a
tracé ceci posé et ceci est le cœur de
mon engagement
politique pouvons-nous mes chers
compatriotes regarder notre système de
protection
sociale notre système de
solidarité comme si rien ne s'était
passé entre 1945 et
2011 je je suis plus que tout autre
attaché à l'idéal
fixé par le général de Gaulle et par le
Conseil nationale de la
résistance mais le seul moyen de
préserver cet
acquis c'est de le réformer en
permanence pour l'adapter aux réalités
de notre
monde dans ce domaine comme dans tous
les
autres j'aimerais tant vous convaincre
mes chers
compatriotes que ce n'est pas la réforme
qui est un danger c'est l'immobilisme
qui est un danger c'est le conservatisme
qui est un danger c'est le refus
d'assumer des
responsabilités et c'est le refus de
voir que le monde change et qu'il ne
nous attendra
pas grâce au progrès de la médecine et à
notre système de santé notre société
connaît aujourd'hui une formidable
révolution celle de l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie et par conséquent un
défi
colossal celui de
l'augmentation de la population la plus
âgée au moment de la
Libération je vous donne ces chiffres
pour vous convaincre que dans cette
affaire ce n'est pas une affaire
d'idéologie de gauche de droite
d'opposition de majorité c'est une
affaire de bon sens de courage de devoir
de prise de
responsabilité au moment de la
Libération l'espérance vie d'un français
était de 62
ans
aujourd'hui 78 ans pour un homme
85 ans pour une
femme qui peut dire qui peut oser
dire que notre
réforme le système de retraite n'était
pas nécessaire alors que de 45 à
aujourd'hui nous sommes passés d'une
espérance de vie de 62 ans à 78 ans pour
les hommes et 85 ans pour les femmes qui
osera le dire au français sans
mentir sans avoir le rouge qui monte à
la
figure à tel point il serait choquant et
pourquoi ne pas le dire scandaleux de ne
pas à ce point vouloir assumer la
responsabilité qui est celle des femmes
et des hommes d'État
en
1960 dans notre
pays il existait 4 cotisants pour un
retraité
aujourd'hui
18 cotisant pour un
retraité et à l'horizon 2050 un cotisant
pour retraité qui osera dire au
français retraiter dormer
tranquille malgré ses chiffres il n'y a
rien à changer il n'y a rien à revoir il
n'y a rien à
dire la société française a profondément
évoluer son environnement s'est
transformé nous vivons dans un monde
ouvert où les produits que nous
consommons tous les jours viennent de
tous les horizons où notre industrie est
confrontée à la concurrence de nouveaux
pays notre modèle social n'est pas
intangible notre modèle social doit
rester
vivant le
réformer l'adapter c'est le sauver et le
péréniser regardons avant tout les
valeurs qui
l'inspirent et auxquell nous sommes
attachés ainsi que les objectifs que
nous voulons
atteindre voulons-nous toujours dépenser
plus sans jamais nous interroger sur les
charges que cela
représente voulons-nous d'un système de
sécurité sociale qui ne serait qu'un
guichet auquel chacun pourrait se servir
comme bon luiemble
ou bien voulons-nous que les droits des
assurés
sociaux répondent aussi au devoir des
assurés sociaux le mot devoir n'est pas
un gros mot il est la contrepartie des
droits le Conseil National de la
Résistance n'a pas voulu d'un système
d'O
il a voulu construire un système digne
pour une France démocratique et
libre la solidarité est totale à une
condition c'est que la responsabilité
soit totale et donc
partagé ce que je souhaite c'est
défendre l'esprit d'une réforme sociale
fondatrcee je ne suis pas le
défenseur organisation corporatiste ou
de faux acquis et en tout cas je
n'accepterai pas le mensonge la
dissimulation de la vérité au prétexte
qu'il y a des rendez-vous électoraux qui
arrivent c'est trop
grave les Français
choisiront mais ils ont le droit à la
vérité pas au
mensonge il y a quelques
semaines
j'avais parlé des nouveaux enjeux qui
s'offrent à notre
pays et que les choses soi
clair nous ne pouvons pas nous n'avons
pas les moyens de le lancer dans une
stratégie de toujours plus de
dépenses pour toujours plus
d'impôts cette stratégie c'est
l'impasse parce que les impôts reposent
sur la France qui travaille qui est en
concurrence avec les
autres et nous les payerons alors de
délocalisation et de perte
d'emploi la vraie réponse la seule passe
par une transformation politiques
sociales il y a quelques semaines
certains acteursavier du système de
santé ont publié un
manifeste dit pour une santé égalitaire
il ne s'agit pas de discuter ici
l'attachement que je crois sincère de
ces personnes à notre système de
santé mais de leur dire vous aussi vous
avez un devoir de responsabilité et à
vous aussi l'irresponsabilité vous est
interdite la principale proposition de
ce manifeste était
simple abandonner tout mécanisme de
maîtrise des dépenses de santé et sans
remettre tenez-vous bien à des
augmentations automatiques des
cotisations cette logique là je la
refuse je la refuserai toujours parce
qu'elle est absurde et qu'elle est
dangereuse je le dis avec d'autant plus
de force que j'ai observé le débat au
Sénat sur le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
nouvelle majorité
sénatoriale propose d'augmenter les
dépenses de long d'ARM de 3,6 % et de
les payer par des augmentations d'impôts
comme c'est
facile les uns promettent des dépenses
et les autres subissent les
augmentations d'impôts je refuse cette
stratégie avec la réforme de l'hôpital
et de la médecine libérale nous avons au
contraire engagé une réorganisation
profondeur de notre système de soins
Roseline bachot il a beaucoup contribué
les maisons de santé per de consolider
de rapprocher l'offre de soins et ça
nous a permis d'obtenir des résultats
l'hôpital a vu son déficit diminué par 3
entre 2007 et
2011 par 3 il est à présent
réorganisé et recentré sur ses missions
au service des malades avec notre
politique du médicament nous concentrons
les remboursements sur les produits les
plus efficaces nous ajustons les prix
selon leur cycle de vie tout en
continuant à soutenir la recherche et
l'innovation dont nous avons absolument
besoin Xavier Bertrand a parfaitement su
tirer tous les enseignements de
l'affaire du Médiator car la confiance
des Français dans notre système
sanitaire doit être préservé par-dessus
tout avec la mise en place du Revenu de
Solidarité Active nous avons écru
l'écart entre les minimas sociaux et les
revenus du travail et nous irons plus
loin dans la des droits et des devoirs
comme l'a proposé Marc Philippe d'bress
d'ici à la fin de l'année nous
expérimenterons dans une dizaine de
départements une obligation de travail
de 7 he pour les bénéficiaires du RSA
une obligation de
travail là aussi que l'homme comprenne
bien ce n'est pas pour
punir c'est au contraire pour
respecter pour donner de la
dignité on n pas de dignité quand on ne
peut survivre qu'en tendant la
main avec notre politique en faveur de
l'emploi des seigneors nous avons voulu
construire de nouvelles relations dans
l'entreprise qui permett de garder les
seigneurs au travail mes chers
compatriotes entre 2007 et 2010 malgré
la
crise le nombre de seigneurs en emploi a
augmenté de
170000 et le taux d'emploi des 55 59 ans
atteint maintenant dans notre pays 62 %
pour la première fois dans notre
histoire nous venons de dépasser la
moyenne
européenne mais quelle était la logique
d'une politique qui consistait à mettre
dehors tous les quincagénè d'une
entreprise alors que dans le même temps
le gouvernement explique qu'il faut
codtiser plus longtemps pour pouvoir
financer nos
retraite avec la réforme des retraites
nous avons donc garanti le principes de
solidarité de notre système par
répartition face à un choc démograique
démographique que chacun voyait
arriver avec le Premier ministre
François
fillant nous avons refusé de baisser le
niveau des pensions de 15 millions de
retraités car baisser leurs
pension cela revenait à remettre en
cause purement et simplement notre Pact
social l'effet d'une telle décision on
été désastreux alors que le grand acquis
de l'après-guerre c'est la fin de la
pauvreté chez nos aînés qui a longtemps
était un fléau typiquement
français et j'ai tenu à respecter mon
engagement de revaloriser le minimum
vieillesse malgré la crise de 25 %
d'augmentation
entre 2007 et
2012 travailler plus longtemps parce que
nous vivons plus longtemps c'était la
seule et unique réponse de bon sens
c'est d'ailleurs mes chers compatriotes
celle qu'on choisit tous les grands pays
développés sous des gouvernements de
droite comme de gauche et je veux le
dire aux Français il n'y avait pas
d'autrees solution ceux qui vous disent
que l'on peut travailler préser notre
système de retraite vous
mente pour combler le déséquilibre de
financement de no retraites il était
nécessaire de travailler plus longtemps
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
relevé l'âge de départ à la retraite à
62 ans ce n'était pas une décision
facile à prendre mais c'était la Seu à
même de préserver le système de retraite
par répartition qui est l'une des
garanties de notre cohésion sociale vous
le voyez bien c'est en adaptant notre
système de protection sociale que nous
garantirons sa
pérenité et c'est dans le même esprit
que nous avons décidé
d'engager une action résolue contre les
fraudes
sociales la
fraude c'est la plus terrible et la plus
insidieuse des
trahisons de
l'esprit de
1945 c'est la fraude qui mine les
fondements mêmes de cette république
social que les frères d'armes de la
Résistance ont voulu battir pour la
France et qu'ils nous ont
légué
frauder que dis-je
voler la sécurité sociale c'est trahir
la confiance de tous les Français et et
c'est pter un coup terrible à la belle
idée nécessaire de solidarité nationale
fruder la sécurité sociale c'est
voler ce n'est pas simplement abuser du
système ce n'est pas simplement profiter
de ces largesses c'est
voler chacun et chacune d'entre
nous celui qui
bénéficie d'un arrêt de travail
frauduleux comme celui qui le
prescrit je le dis simplement vole les
Français tous les
Français celui qui minore ses
ressources pour obtenir une
prestation vole les
Français celui qui perçoit des
allocations familiales alors qu'il ne
réside pas sur le territoire
national comme celui qui invente un
logement
fictif lou un logement salu pour
détourner des
prestations VO les
Français celui qui emploie un salarié
sans déclarer à la sécurité sociale
triche au détriment de la
collectivité je vous le dis nous devons
être sans
indulgence contre les
frotteurs et contre les tricheurs il ne
s'agit pas dans mon
esprit de désigner des B
émissaires de monter les uns contre les
autres cela n'aurait aucun
sens il s'agit de préserver un acquis
social si la fraude prospère nous ne
pourrons pas garder notre modèle
social qui de lutter contre la
fraude sont ceux qui préparent la
désagrégation de notre modèle
social trop longtemps mes chers
compatriotes il fut de bon ton dans
certains milieux de ni la
fraude dénoncer la fraude était même
déplacer ce qui dénonc la fraude était
même
condamné par ces beaux esprits qui
voyait là une sorte de
redistribution
militante et bien cette période
elle est définitivement derrière nous
depuis
2008 nous avons mis notre système de
sécurité sociale en situation
d'identifier et de réprimer la fraude et
les
fraudeurs l'interconnexion des fichiers
entre administration dans le respect des
règles applicables
est absolument indispensable je veux
d'ailleurs souligner et saluer le rôle
des parlementaires qui ont construit
avec le gouvernement cet arsenal de
lutte contre la fraude à la sécurité
sociale je veux aussi parce que c'est
mon devoir de chef de l'État souligner
l'investissement de l'ensemble des
agents des services de l'État et des
caisses de sécurité sociale dans ce
travail et notamment le rôle des
inspecteurs et des contrôleurs qui font
chaque jour sur le
terrain est très difficile et c'est mon
devoir de leur rendre hommage une caisse
àocation familiale comme la Gironde
distribue 1illard 300 millions de
prestations
familiales je veux rendre hommage à ces
fonctionnaires parce qu'ils sont en
première ligne du
mécontentement des protestations et
parce que les contrôles c'est toujours
bon pour le
voisin est toujours douloureux pour
soi-même vous pouvez être fier de votre
administration oh bien sûr tout ne va
pas comme on souhaiterait que ça aille
mais nous avons la chance dans notre
pays d'avoir une administration
compétente et honnête et j'ai voulu dire
à ces fonctionnaires que je comprenais
que leur métier était difficile d'autant
plus et je le revendique je l'assume
j'ai voulu le choix de no remplacement
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux parce que la
France ne peut plus continuer à
multiplier
les emplois publics et bien les premiers
résultats de cette politique de
fermeté sont là en 2010 3 milliards et
demi d'euros de fraude fiscale sociale
et douanière ont été détecté don un DEM
milliards d'euros au titre des
organismes de sécurité
sociale simplement parce que nous
l'avons voulu c'est 20 % de plus qu'en
2009 il est évident que cette politique
de lutte contre la fraude n'est pas la
réponse structurelle à nos problèmes de
déficit ce qu'ils
disent se
trompe parce que dans mon esprit c'est
une exigence absolue de
responsabilité et de bonne gestion de
l'argent public alors cette exigence est
celle qui nous conduit enfin à
poursuivre dans la voie du redressement
de nos finances
publiques notre volonté de maîtrise des
publi n'est pas une obsession comptable
mes chers compatriotes ce qui est en
jeu c'est la maîtrise de notre
destin c'est notre indépendance
nationale c'est notre capacité à assumer
notre souveraineté
nationale seul un pays qui maîtrise ses
finances peut demeurer
souverain et pour cela nous ne pouvons
pas continuer à distribuer plus de
richesse que nous n'en
produisons nous ne pouvons pas financer
nos régimes de protection sociale par la
dette qui se crée automatiquement quand
année après année nos dépenses sociales
restent supérieures aux recettes qui
sont censé les financer c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons décidé avec le
Premier ministre d'augmenter de 1 % un
certain nombre de prestations sociales
en cohérence avec les dernières
prévisions de croissance on augmentera
les prestations à duup prorata de la
richesse que nous serons capables de
créer nous avons pu tenir l'objectif
national des dépenses d'assurance
maladie pour
2010 tenez-vous bien c'est la première
fois depuis
1997 que cela se produit dans notre
pays et nous le tiendrons en 2011 et
nous le tiendrons en 2012 et pour les
années suivantes un am difficile à 2
et5i % et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons décidé d'accélérer le
calendrier de la réforme des retraites
pour restaurer plus rapidement
l'équilibre des régimes de retraite et
protéger les
retraités savez-vous qu'avant notre
réforme sur 15 millions de retraités en
France pour 1 million et demi d'entre
eux la sécurité sociale était obligé
d'emprunter à la banque un ent qu'elle
n'avait
pas est-ce que ce système pouvait
perdurer
non c'était impossible Mesdames et
Messieurs les pensions de retraite en
Grèce ont baissé de 20
% voilà ce qui arrive à un pays qui vit
au-dessus de ces moyens au
Portugal les pensions de retraite ont
également
baissé voilà ce qui arrive un pays qui
n'a pas fait att temp la réforme qui
était
nécessaire nous ne voulons pas de ces
évolutions pour notre
pays protéger les retraités d'une baisse
des pensions qui ferait à nouveau rimer
vieillesse et pauvreté nous ne pouvons
pas
l'accepter que le statut de notre modèle
de financement n'est plus
possible sera ma
conclusion nous devons repenser le
système de financement de notre système
social il en va de la compétitivité de
notre pays dans un monde ouvert soumis à
la concurrence le coût très élevé du
travail dans notre pays pénalise notre
économie et pénaliser la France dans la
compétition internationale c'est
accroîre le risque de
délocalisation le coût du travail a
augmenté en France plus rapidement qu'en
Allemagne sur les 15 dernières années
n'allez pas chercher ailleurs les bons
résultats de l'Allemagne et les
difficultés de la
France deux décisions qui ont été prises
ont eu des conséquences catastrophiques
sur la compétitivité de la France la
première c'est celle du début des années
80 quand on a fait croire aux Français
qu'on pouvait passer l'âge de départ à
la retraite de 65 ans à 60 ans on a
menti au français tout le monde le
savait et cette décision a été prise en
niant les
réalités et puis au début des années
2000 avec l'invraisemblable affaire des
35 heur dont nous avons été le seul pays
au monde à nous
don il nous faut à présent ouvrir un
débat serein sur le financement de notre
protection
sociale sur ce sujet nous ne sommes pas
sur un terrain vierge beaucoup de
travaux ont d'ors et déjà été engagés
pour analyser les différentes hypothèses
quelle disposition pouvons-nous prendre
pour réduire le poids de la taxation sur
le travail c'est une question
essentielle le financement de la
protection sociale doit-il reposer
autant sur les salaires alors que nos
partenaires européens et mondiaux font
un choix différent et que nos salariés
sont de plus en plus mis en
concurrence dans quelle proportion
faut-il mettre à contribution différents
types d'impôts pour réaliser cet
élargissement les importations
doivent-elles dans notre pays contribuer
au financement de notre modèle social
ces questions là au-delà du sujet du
coût du travail
la meilleure intégration des couvertures
offertes par les organismes
complémentaires à la protection des
différents risques sociaux ce débat nous
concerne tous Je propose d'installer le
Haut Conseil du financement de la
protection sociale qui associera les
partenaires sociaux ce conseil engagera
le débat public sur ces questions qui
sont au cœur de notre Pact social et de
son avenir il nous aidera à poursuivre
dans la voie du redressement des
différentes branches de la sécurité
sociale je souhaite que ce au Conseil
commence à travailler avant la fin de
l'année qu'il apporte de la sérénité du
sérieux et de l'objectivité dans ce
débat je lui demanderai de faire des
propositions qui soient à l'auteur de
l'ambition que je porte pour notre
modèle social et dans quelques mois
chacun de ceux qui envisagent les
prochaines
échéances aura à se prononcer sur une
question absolument centrale celle du
financement de notre modèle
mes chers compatriotes j'espère que vous
l'avez compris pour moi ce déplacement
était très
important nous allons garder notre
modèle
social nous avons tous vu des images
outre
atlantique quand un homme une femme
perdait son emploi et se retrouv dans un
mobil sans rien ce modèle là nous n'en
voulons pas nous ne jugons pas les
autres mais nous n'en voulons pas il ne
correspond pas ce que nous
sommes mais dans le même temps nous
voyons aussi où se trouve et dans quelle
situation se trouve des pays qui ont
vécu sans se préoccuper du lendemain ces
modèles là nous n'en voulons pas non
plus bien sûr que nous voulons continuer
avec un modèle généreux mais nous ne
voulons pas non plus qu'on abuse de ce
modèle nous ne voulons pas non plus
qu'on manque de respect à notre système
social et à notre p
en considérant qu'on peut tout lui
demander et rien lui donner cela nous ne
l'accepterons jamais parce que ce n'est
pas conforme à
l' et c'est en cel que nous ser fidèles
à l'héritage du général de Gaulle et de
ceux qui ont fait le Conseil National de
la
Résistance mesdames et messieurs la
crise est loin d'être fini
elle crée beaucoup de souffrance dans
notre
pays impose que chacun soit à la hauteur
de cette crise en assumant ses
responsabilités quels que soi les
risques que les responsables en cours
assumer ses responsabilités et faire son
devoir mais cette crise qui oblige à
repenser nos
idées à réfléchir sur ce que nous sommes
et vers où nous voulons aller est aussi
une
opportunité pour la France de réagir AG
de préparer son avenir et de rester dans
le Ploton de tête des nations qui
comptent dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
refuser le 21e siècle n'a aucun
sens refuser la mondialisation n'a aucun
sens peser sur la
mondialisation réformer le modèle
français et compter pour la France afin
que vos enfants puissent vivre dans un
pays en qu'ils auront confiance et dont
ils
fier comme nous l'avons tous cessé été
de ces manifestations du 11 novembre
faire rimer patriotisme vers l'avenir et
pas simplement vers le passé aimer la
France être fier de la France redresser
la France construire la France voilà ce
que je souhaite de cette ville de
Bordeaux qui m'a reçu aujourd'hui avec
tant de chaleur et tant d'amitié merci
Monsieur le Maire merci
monsieur
[Musique]